[Music]
our governments always control their
content
but fight for freedom we've just never
paid attention freedom of speech
there's a very small group of people
that influence all the companies that we
watch
that's why we have q patriots everywhere
stand at the ready q is completely basis
it's
the rantings and ravings of anonymous
people who we don't know it may be
multiple people it may be different
people it may be one person
q has not foretold anything despite the
fact that many people who
are believers in q will try to convince
you through different
signals and small things that you might
not have picked up that it actually
is all true you know it's not true this
is insane
q anon offers a constantly shifting
way to view the world as it's happening
which means that it's very easy for
people who believe it
to then discard any attempt to
reason with them and explain why they
shouldn't believe it
it's almost seeped into the groundwater
of the internet now
[Music]
[Applause]
you know for a long time reporters have
been trying and have been openly
wondering
who is cute who is this anonymous person
making the post it's
one letter but it spells out a bizarre
conspiracy theory
with president trump at the center
obviously the president knows what q
anon is
well i don't know much about the
movement other than i understand they
like me very much
almost equally as important as to
whoever q
is is who runs these sites like qmap
people like this are just as influential
in spreading the conspiracy as cue
themselves
q is a pretty interesting case study in
how you move
a fringe idea into the mainstream
i had had a personal curiosity as to who
was behind
qmap before you know i really felt that
it warranted
kind of a deeper investigation the place
to start was
to go and talk to him so i rented a car
and i drove out to new jersey
my name is william turton i'm a cyber
security reporter at bloomberg news
i'm joshua brustein i'm a writer for
bloomberg news and businessweek magazine
i'm one of the two writers on this story
about qmap.pub
[Music]
jason galinas is a pretty normal
sounding guy
he is a dad in new jersey three children
lives in berkeley heights which is a
town about an hour outside of new york
city
jason in many ways was your typical
american he got a degree
he you know went into working in the
technology departments of different
banks
he was a senior employee at citibank
where he managed over 100 employees
and you know the last major project he
worked on there was an artificial
intelligence project at city
[Music]
jason galenas also ran one of the
if not the biggest q and on conspiracy
website
like many people who are now deeply into
q anon
jason seemed to express the beginnings
of interest in these kind of theories
during the obama administration
we were able to speak to friends one of
whom told us that
you know about the time obama was
elected jason
described obama to him as the antichrist
he seemed a lot of anger towards the
obama administration
and began to explore some unconventional
shall we say beliefs
one of them related to the idea that
hillary clinton was involved
in sex trafficking
you know we don't know for sure if jason
believed in pizzagate as it's formerly
known but
but friends told us that he believed in
this idea that powerful democratic
officials including hillary clinton
were involved in the sex trafficking of
children this all goes back to russian
hackers leaking john podesta's emails
you might recall those were posted on
wikileaks and users
on the image board 4chan started reading
those
emails and decided that the word pizza
meant children and kind of worked
themselves up into this idea that
in the basement of a pizza shop in dc
were secret tunnels
leading to congress where they're sex
trafficking children one of the big
surprises of the presidential campaign
was the explosion
of fake news on the internet fantastic
tales that some believe to be true
at one point far into the conspiracy
theory someone actually showed up there
with
a with an assault rifle and shot it
inside
the restaurant before realizing that the
basement he was looking for
that would have presumably held the
children did not even exist
twenty-eight-year-old edgar welch was
arrested in washington sunday afternoon
outside comet ping pong a popular family
pizza parlor
d.c police say welch fired at least one
round into the restaurant floor with an
ar-15 rifle like this one
on his facebook page he recently pleaded
guilty
but this became a huge phenomenon which
kind of set the stage for q anon
[Music]
so cue drops as they're called are
posted to this website called aitkoon
which is formerly called
8chan they're formally posted on 4chan
and they can come
daily a few days apart or multiple times
a day
in october 2017 a anonymous
user who called themselves q posted a
message
saying that hillary clinton would be
arrested
that this would lead to planned riots
and that this would kind of be the
beginning
of the apocalypse now this sounds really
weird
it wasn't actually all that unusual for
4chan at the time
there were a fair number of posts
from people purporting to be high-level
government officials revealing secrets
and the q anon account was one of them
there was an fbi and on there was a cia
and on
and for whatever reason this is
the one that took off this is a movement
where you get information that's all it
is
it's up to you how you want to take it
follow the plan trust the plan the great
awakening
you know there's a lot of reasons why
someone might believe in q anon and
it actually you know is why people
believe in conspiracies in general i
think
now more than ever there's kind of
distrust in
the media in this shared set of facts
it's all about control look at the
science show me the science with a mask
because i'll show you science the virus
goes right through the mask
the coronavirus probably drove people
deeper into their kind of
silos and their holes many of the
followers will sometimes talk about how
they've been alienated from their
friends and family
but will say you know i have my q family
there are a handful of q aggregators
including qmap which have taken
the cue drops and posted them in more
friendly web environments devoid of some
of the
pornography and other things that are on
the websites where the original cue
drops are
so keymap was started in april 2018.
what keymap did that was so interesting
was that it took it one step further not
only did it aggregate the post
it also kind of wrote out these themes
and players so
it was really easy to navigate and this
to me was one of the biggest revelations
in my reporting
when we found deleted posts from jason
galinas
where he explained on twitter how he
designed the site like this
intentionally to make it as accessible
to as many people as possible as he
called it
he was onboarding normies into the
conspiracy
you know if you wanted to read more
about the secret pedophile cabal
great or if you want to read about the
secret plot to take down mike flynn
for example trump's former national
security advisor boom there's a theme
you can go to and read all about it
[Music]
in recent weeks two researchers at this
startup in the uk
called logically published this really
interesting and fascinating report
that outed jason as the person behind
qmap so logically ai is
a small operation that looks to
expose disinformation through basically
internet forensics we use
a lot of data streams it's then up to us
as the investigators and the users to
pair that information down
look for trends look for patterns my
name is
joe andrak i am the senior investigator
at logically.ai we
are a primarily a fact-checking company
but we also do
investigations and editorial into
disinformation and misinformation
online and they began looking into qmap
in the late summer because they felt
like it was a way that people were
becoming radicalized
and wanted to figure out who was behind
it
there was a url with an email address in
it and from there we were able to find
google chrome store page for qmap.pub
and the qmap app that he was running
that had since been deleted by
google play when they realized they were
starting to crack down on q and all
because he was monetizing these apps he
had to register them under a company
which led us to patriot platforms llc
and obviously if he'd registered for an
llc there would be
filings with names attached to it that
we could then explore so we
pursued open business records we looked
at those which gave us the name jason
galinas
i saw the report i was like this is
really interesting i mean this is
fascinating but you know they hadn't
gone to jason for comment
you know it was kind of just put out
there on the website the first thing i
did was
i rented a car and i drove out to new
jersey and i
found jason in his front yard he
was holding a wheelbarrow while some
landscapers and and laborers around him
were doing work on the hedges and
in the lawn and i felt really nervous i
walked over and i said
hi jason i'm a reporter from bloomberg i
just wanted to ask you about this report
that's been published that says that you
run this website
he was a little evasive he kind of
walked away from me and i was able to
kind of
get him to continue talking but you know
never denied running the site and
eventually said that
qmap was a patriotic movement to save
the country you know eventually
his wife appeared at the front door who
kind of beckoned him inside
i went and knocked on the door a second
time really in the effort to try and
give him as much opportunity to comment
or clarify as possible
he didn't respond once i was in my car
multiple police suvs
arrived and informed me that jason had
called police
once jason knew he was found out he took
down
his entire online presence as well as
his wife's
online presence and pretty much
disappeared from the internet
qmap.pub also came down
and was basically just a couple of links
to other
q anon aggregators after our first
article that came out that noted jason
was an employee at citigroup
the company placed him on paid leave
it's unclear where jason is now but
city actually fired jason galinas after
you know almost 13 years at the company
you know the reason they get for firing
him is that you know working city is a
really highly regulated place and you
have to disclose to the company
your your income outside and you know he
was in theory making money off this
q and on website on patreon and he never
disclosed that to his company
qmap coming down will probably not have
a huge impact on the viability
of the q anon community at this point it
is large enough to be pretty adaptable
you've seen it pop up in many
places overseas and it really serves
as a sort of proxy for extreme distrust
of any institutions and q has served as
a pretty effective
vehicle for that kind of feeling i stand
before you tonight
honored by your support i think it kind
of goes back to this idea that
people are disillusioned with kind of
what's happening in the world that are
more likely to believe conspiracy
theories
i think that's what makes cue appealing
it's finally an answer to all the weird
and strange things that are happening in
the world